I'm checking out Hamburg today it's
sometimes called the Gateway to the
world because of its port the city in
general is characterized by water as
well as the Elbe River there is the elta
and many canals Moin Moin that's what
the residents here say instead of hello
some people really think that Hamburg is
located by the sea but it's still
another hundred kilometres along the
Elbe to the North Sea and today I'll be
looking for hamburg's most beautiful
places on the water the sample EPS
Orlando glutton used to be an important
part of the harbour steamships used to
dock here but over the past couple of
centuries the port has moved away from
the city center so now ferries and tour
boats arrive and leave from the London's
blue a harbor cruise that's what I want
to do today but I've chosen something
special it's a bus that also floats on
the water only in Hamburg would people
think of something this crazy
the city harbour tour starts in the
spacious not a UNESCO World Heritage
Site since 2015 it's a huge warehouse
complex with distinctive red brick
architecture imported goods like coffee
and cocoa used to be stored here
we travel on land for 25 minutes then
the moment arrives we roll into the Elbe
well our bus really float
the horn is the signal that we're now
traveling as a riverboat totally bizarre
it's the only amphibious bus in Germany
I asked the driver if he still finds it
weird suddenly driving off the road into
the water but he reassures me and
explains how it all works
there is one engine for Road use and two
more for the water in addition it's all
completely sealed so no water can get in
from below and what about the wheels
water the axles are raised by 40
centimeters so the wheels don't hang so
deep and give less resistance I know I'm
not supposed to but can I accelerate him
carefully not suddenly
you trust me right that's it that's all
that's enough I'll pull it back
okay yeah
I'm now in the center of Hamburg in
front of the Town Hall
it looks pretty grand and it
demonstrates the pride of free citizens
here because Hamburg was never ruled by
a king Imperial Chancellor or Prince
what city can say that about itself by
the way the arcades behind me are a
great place to go shopping this looks
like a lake but it's actually the river
I stopped a tributary of the Elbe the
young fun stick is a Boulevard running
along its banks Hamburg and the harbour
are also worth seeing by night
and early morning the fish market opens
at 5:00 a.m. every Sunday it's 300 years
old
you can buy everything here
including of course fresh fish great the
bread rolls still warm and that's from
this morning and the salmon is excellent
what's that what's that crowd of people
around the florists high school guy
yelled McCoy oh I see here it's the show
that counts I'd like to have a go I
sneak onto the wagon and ask the Dutch
flower seller how he convinces people to
buy flowers at 6:00 in the morning he
gives me a bonsai plant and tells me
what to say I start at 10 euros and the
price goes down and down in the end I
managed to sell it for two euros maybe I
could get a jump here not bad for a
first try
what an atmosphere shouting merchants
mixed with the exhausted party crowd
coming straight from the Reeperbahn
weird but interesting at the same time
and if you have any energy left
you can keep partying in the fish
auction hall
and outside the new day is already
starting I'm really exhausted but I had
a great day in Hamburg I really like the
mentality of the people here maybe it's
because of the harbour that the
residents have remained so open-minded
towards new things over the centuries
I'm going to mr. Harbor the next
tourists are already arriving but I
really have to get some sleep
ahoy and see you soon